Por qué genera alarma el hecho de que la
planta desapoli ya funcione con reservas
de combustible a ver la central nuclear
produce energía no todos los reactores
están funcionando pero los circuitos de
refrigeración necesitan una fuente
externa los circuitos refrigeración son
los que mantienen la temperatura bajo
control si hay alguna avería que afecte
a esos circuitos a esos cables de
electricidad que alimentan nuestros
circuitos refrigeración o hay algún
problema con las reservas de combustible
que los mantienen que saltan los hace
que funcionen los generadores en caso de
emergencia pues tendríamos un problema
con el con el núcleo de la central qué
ocurriría en un eventual escenario en
que se acaben absolutamente las reservas
pues no podríamos poner una situación
muy parecida a la de fukushima en el
caso de fukushima lo que estalló fue el
los núcleos del reactor después de que
la ola del tsunami con el agua salada
había provocado unas enormes cortos
circuitos en los circuitos de
refrigeración O sea que es una situación
en la que se interrumpe la electricidad
de los circuitos refrigeración se
recalienta el núcleo de la central y
revienta Entonces es una situación en la
que esperemos que no nos veamos nunca la
cuestión es que estamos en el caso
inaudito de una central nuclear en medio
de un país en guerra absolutamente ahora
como experto en materia de seguridad no
Qué medida cree que deberían tomarse
para resguardar la central de esa
polilla pues esto Solamente se puede
solucionar o podemos evitar el peligro
con la presencia de actores neutrales y
externos esto supone que bien tiene que
haber observadores de Naciones Unidas y
sobre todo y los técnicos del personal
técnico de la organización Internacional
de la energía atómica que es los que
pueden super que la central nuclear está
en las condiciones adecuadas para que no
lleguemos a ese escenario Terrible y
digo que es una tiene que ser actores
neutrales y externos porque Claro en
medio de una zona de conflicto ambos
bandos de confianza ambos bandos se
echan la culpa de cualquier incidente
que tiene que haber el riesgo el
problema de esto que parece muy fácil de
decir mandar allí cascos azules o mandar
observadores con un casco blanco y un
peto que ponga Naciones Unidas
organización internacional de energía
atómica es que van a tener que
la seguridad de estos observadores se
basa en la buena voluntad de las partes
y eso es muy arriesgado es poner la vida
en riesgo de personas que solamente aquí
estamos viendo en pantalla los
observadores de la organización
internacional energía atómica que lo
único que les va a proteger de un
conflicto es la buena voluntad de las
partes de respetar lo que simboliza la
bandera de las Naciones Unidas o lo que
simboliza esta
este organismo internacional Entonces es
una cuestión de buena voluntad de buena
fe y de confiar en que para ambos bandos
es imprescindible que no lleguemos
escenario terrible absolutamente bueno
quisiera planteárselo Jesús imaginemos
El peor escenario posible no ocurre un
desastre nuclear qué dimensiones
tendrían las consecuencias
la explosión de un reactor nuclear en
Ucrania viendo pues las corrientes los
vientos sobre todas las vimos en el caso
de Chernobyl en este caso de chernóbil
que estoy afectó a toda Europa los
vientos empujaron el polvo radiactivo
hasta escandinavia y aquí por ejemplo en
España durante los siguientes años se
los médicos contrataron el aumento del
número de cáncers o sea que de enfermos
afectados es una cuestión epidemiológica
decir que es una cuestión de porcentaje
no es que haya aquí en España si hubiese
pues muertes masivas pero vamos esto
tendría consecuencias medioambientales
tendría evidentemente habría una zona
alrededor en el que habría Pues un
elevado número de fallecido Y
evidentemente esto no se quedaría la
cuestión es que no quedaría contenido
Ucrania sino que nos afectaría aquí en
Europa a todos los países